do you smell her or smell things that
remind you of her of my grandmother um
roses remind me of my grandmother mhm I
put rose on every morning for her so
know that she is with you and does not
want you to feel bad about not saying
goodbye to her do you understand that
she says you have carried this burden
way too long she says he was my little
sidekick yeah so know that she wants to
thank you for the way that you love and
honor her every day of your life yes I
did you get married after she
passed y cuz she goes I was at the
wedding I go you were and she says I
wouldn't have missed it for the world
she goes I had a front row Teresa did
you lay a rose for her always roses for
her she cuz she just showed me an empty
chair with one rose on it that's why I
asked you that so validating that the
souls are all together and not wanting
you to carry the burden of not being
able to say goodbye